des questions ça concerne le
jaunissement à la télé
alors ça concerne pas Cyril je crois que
non
non aujourd'hui on voulait en parler
peut-être avec vous est-ce que le
jeunisse à la télé c'est pas dépassé
alors oui
attendez voilà écoutez on veut on se dit
Michel Drucker qui fait qui fait son
retour effectivement beaucoup de
personnalités qui ont plus de 50 ans
aujourd'hui et qui continue à faire des
cartons est-ce que le jaunissement n'est
pas dépassé c'est complètement dépassé
et je vais vous dire le génisme c'est un
fantasme que tous les dirigeants de
chaîne ont cherché à assouvir à toutes
les époques je vais vous raconter cette
anecdote très rapide août 1989 Michel
Drucker reçoit sur son canapé mais chez
lui cette fois-ci à domicile pour un
déjeuner Philippe Guillaume qui à ce
moment là et PDG de France Télévisions
il lui dit droit dans les yeux Michel
Drucker vous êtes un homme du passé la
télé de demain se fera sans vous Michel
Drucker aujourd'hui il est où il est sur
France 3 on est en 2023 il a 80 ans et
il continue à animer une émission de
télévision donc je vais vous dire il
faut être pragmatique il faut regarder
les chiffres et si une personne de plus
de 50 ans continue à fédérer de nombreux
téléspectateurs et bien il faut la
garder et le retour de Michel Drucker
c'était le dimanche 27 août d'environ
dimanche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci de votre accueil qui me voit droit
au cœur un cœur qui bat un peu plus vite
aujourd'hui parce que j'attends ça
depuis si longtemps et vous êtes là
fidèle merci de vos encouragements
d'avoir soutenu pendant ces longs mois
je suis content d'être là
merci c'était très touchant et Michel
Drucker continue à très bien fonctionner
oui mais il est j'allais dire il est
hors sol c'est déjà c'est quasiment une
question de superstition la télé va avec
Michel Drucker Michel Drucker va avec la
télé il partira quand lui il aura décidé
ou que ça sentait l'obligera la chaîne
le gardera tout le temps des
personnalités comme William Leymergie
alors ça a vraiment être toujours été
très crétin de parler de tranche d'âge
parce que c'est là en fort personnalité
il était acide caustique quand il avait
20 ans il l'est toujours il n'a pas
changé il a pris quelques rides mais il
a pas changé donc c'est vrai que un
génisse mais France Télévisions et
toutes les chaînes un petit peu mais je
pense télévision est tombée dans le
piège pardon on a vu Cyril quand ils ont
vu Cyril Féraud ils sont dit il faut que
des jeunes et ça a été ça prédisposée à
la vague de licenciement brutaux on va
parler déduction brutale l'énergie aussi
qui continue de très bien drôle
monsieur bonjour toute l'équipe de
William à midi est heureuse de vous
retrouver un quel est heureuse
j'espère que vous avez pris des vacances
et quel fut bonne on va reprendre donc
ce rendez-vous quotidien sur C8 à
l'heure du déjeuner c'est 12h30 un
désormais même si aujourd'hui on
commence un petit peu plus tard un petit
peu plus William l'énergie avant cet été
les matins maintenant c'est à la tranche
de la mi-journée et voilà mais William
l'énergie c'est un visage aussi de
envisage audiovisuel en plus ils sont
pas cons ils savent que quand ils
forment une bande et Cyril le
spécialiste de ça on met toutes les
tranches d'âge donc il y en a entre
guillemets pour tout le monde moi je
veux donner un tout petit exemple Gérard
Hernandez dans scène de ménage quand il
a accepté il avait passé 75 ans et moi
il avait hésité il m'avait demandé parce
qu'on se connaît depuis longtemps il
m'avait dit mais je veux pas le faire
Isabelle j'ai essayé j'ai plus que l'âge
de la retraite c'est ridicule les gens
vont pas m'aimer résultat ben hélas
Marion Game est parti lui il reste il
était toujours plébiscité par les
téléspectateurs il a maintenant 90 ans
et les gens l'AD toujours et lui il a
l'intention de continuer alors ça ce
sont pour effectivement les
présentateurs les journalistes et les
animateurs qui continuent de fonctionner
sur sur vos antennes sur vos chaînes il
y a aussi ceux qui ont été mis de côté
et pourquoi on en parle aujourd'hui
c'est parce qu'hier dans tes PMP patrick
Montel pousse un énorme coup de gueule
il a demandé de pouvoir participer aux
Jeux Olympiques il n'arrive pas à
décrocher une accréditation lorsque l'on
a un certain âge on est bon à mettre à
la poubelle en France alors moi je te
dis ça oui parce que je le pense
sincèrement je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a
un vrai problème avec l'âge c'est qu'on
juge les gens non pas sur leurs
compétences non pas sur ce qu'ils
peuvent apporter à une entreprise mais
on les juge aussi sur les sur leur état
civil et ça c'est juste insupportable
alors est toujours là
Nelson Monfort aussi et je m'en réjouis
je m'en réjouis les chaînes font une
erreur d'analyse selon moi de départ
c'est qu'elle pense que parce qu'ils
vont mettre un animateur jeune ou une
animatrice jeune forcément le public
jeune va venir c'est vrai que l'audience
Hérode il y a un bassin de jeunes qu'il
faut absolument attirer la télévision et
ces jeunes qui ont tendance même à aller
vers les plateformes donc on comprend
cette logique de vouloir attirer les
jeunes mais pas en mettant des des
animateurs jeunes pas forcément je vous
donne cet exemple de Jean-Luc Reichmann
par exemple qui tous les midis anime les
douze coups de midi et Jean-Luc
Reichmann
sur la cible par exemple des quatre 14
ans on est quand même sur la cible plus
jeune là il peut rassembler jusqu'à 38%
de part d'audience 40% de part
d'audience sur les 15 24 ans et pourtant
Jean-Luc Reichmann il a pas 30 ans il a
il a passé la barre de la soixantaine
donc vous voyez c'est l'exemple qui
montre que c'est c'est pareil pour les
séries regardez quand je peux toujours
manger là mais France 3 vieilles séries
vieux acteurs il y en a marre c'est
possible effectivement c'est très peu de
femmes et de jeunes devant mais du coup
ils s'en sont débarrassés Canal+ le
groupe Canal intelligemment les a
récupérés ça fait au minima un minimum
un million trois millions quatre c'est
énorme
France 300 morts les doigts et alors
qu'il aurait passé sur France 5 ça
aurait très très bien marché donc voilà
c'est stupide de réagir comme ça alors
parmi les personnes n'hésitez
personnalités et quelle personnalité du
paysage audiovisuel par France
Télévisions notamment il y a Patrick
Sébastien Patrick Sébastien qui est
carton d'audience et qui a été poussé
vers la sortie par France Télévisions
d'ailleurs il s'était confié sur son
éviction sur le plateau TPMP
de marché de l'année des prime
exactement et là
[Musique]
c'est ton dernier réveillon
sur TV5 Monde ça a dû faire 70 millions
de personnes donc c'est des gens qui
existent tous ces gens là et on leur a
dit bon c'est pas pour vous c'est pas
grave moi je m'en fous je vais faire
autre chose c'est tu me dis tu me disais
que tu étais très heureux à moi là je
suis la reine des neiges là
et après il est pas libéré délivré non
plus parce que on sent qu'il en a gros
sur la patate Patrick Sébastien c'est
vrai que le plus grand cabaret du monde
c'était son bébé c'est voilà c'était ça
sa raison de vivre d'une certaine
manière mais il faut savoir que c'est
une émission qui était très coûteuses
qui c'est vrai federait beaucoup de
téléspectateurs de nombreux générations
étaient bercé par cette émission et
Patrick Sébastien il a porté quelque
chose à la télévision aujourd'hui les
rediffusions de ces émissions sur C8
quand elles sont en prime time
atteignent régulièrement le million de
téléspectateurs ce qui prouve bien que
un Patrick Sébastien aujourd'hui n'est
pas complètement désuet oui avec Patrick
Sébastien c'est qu'on le format pas
Patrick il est comme il est donc il est
grande gueule ils disent qu'il a à dire
et tout et que ça dans un univers un peu
frileux ça n'a pas plu non plus on pense
aussi à Thierry Beccaro qui a choisi
après 29 ans 29 ans de présentation de
Motus de quitter d'arrêter l'émission il
s'en était expliqué lui-même il disait
que c'était un choix personnel il s'en
est expliqué vous allez peut-être le
voir voilà motus marche toujours très
bien mais je ne voulais pas
[Musique]
une émission faut pas le faire parce
qu'on se sent vieux je trouve que c'est
pas un bon argument ça a surtout quand
on a un vivier téléspectateur aussi
important on le fait pas parce qu'on se
sent mieux on le fait parce que les
autres vont pas sentir que vous êtes
mieux
regarde tu résistes
non mais franchement c'est du nez
élégance rare Damien élégance